Bonjour à tous.
J'ai une voix beaucoup plus grave que d'habitude car je suis très malade.
Ça sonne grave non, plus que d'habitude ?
Ouah John est impressionné, c'est bon signe, je suis très heureux!
Aujourd'hui, vidéo setup, je suis un peu ému.
Après plusieurs semaines de travaux...
... c'est faux.
Ça a duré une semaine mais j'fais genre que c'était très long etc. et que j'en ai souffert.
Je vais vous montrer mon nouveau décor, et surtout l'endroit où je vais passer beaucoup de temps cette année,
parce que, au-delà du décor, il y a aussi un espace pour écrire, un espace pour se poser, et kiffer avec ses potes.
Bref, vous allez voir tout ça dans un instant.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
C'est quoi ça ?
Ah c'est mon livre, putain !
Qui est dispo à la Fnac et sur Amazon et tout... C'est mon livre c'est ouf.
Yes, alors le décor !
*Expiration* Je suis un peu ému...
On y va, John ? C'est parti !
*Musique joyeuse*
*Disque rayé* Hop hop hop hop ! Attention attention attention, John !
Ne donnons pas aux gens ce qu'ils veulent tout de suite voir !
Pense à mon watchtime, John !
On manipule, on est là pour manipuler tout ça, nous !
Messieurs dames, bienvenue dans ce merveilleux espace de vie,
où les auteurs et moi-même pourront écrire et avoir des réunions dignes de ce nom,
sur une table adéquate.
On a mis du parquet, vous l'avez remarqué?
*Rire* Cette transition devait être pas mal !
J'ai fait mettre du parquet parce que j'trouve c'est plus chaleureux !
Mec, j'suis en mode Valérie Damidot,
j'suis parti, j'suis lancé, plus personne peut m'arrêter.
Nous avons ici une petite étagère,
que je regarde régulièrement.
Quand je regarde à cet endroit, c'est pour me rappeler à quel point mon frère est plus fort que moi à Tekken
et de ne plus jamais rejouer avec lui.
Quand je regarde à cet endroit,
c'est pour me rappeler à quel point je suis le boss, quoi
dix millions d'abonnés, je suis clairement un monstre, quoi.
Ici, très important : le mégaphone, accessoire *parle dans le mégaphone* favori de Lucas.
Et ici, en bas...
Mec, c'est quoi, gros ?
Mec, je passe pour un putain d'alcoolique !
Écoutez-moi bien, je vous promets, je n'ai jamais mis cette bouteille là.
Qui a mis une bouteille de champagne ici ?
Eh ben attends, c'est le moment en vrai, c'est le moment.
Oh non, j'ai envie de secouer, j'ai jamais fait de ma vie !
A la fin de la vidéo...
Pourquoi j'ai dit ça, John ? Pour le...
*souffle la réponse* ... "watchtime".
(John) Pour le watchtime !
(Squeezie) Voilà ! Bien joué !
*Musique triste*
Et ici, on a un petit espace pour se poser
et jouer,
on va pas se mentir,
à Smash Bros.
C'est vraiment *rire*...
Regardez d'ailleurs, il y a juste une Switch,
il n'y a rien d'autre : ni PS4 ni Xbox.
Ici, c'est SMASH !
Pourquoi cette grande télé ?
Pour qu'on voit bien son perso même quand on joue à huit !
Les joueurs de Smash comprendront tout ça...
Je fais partie, de cette catégorie de gens,
qui mettent des feux de camps sur leur écran.
C'est chaleureux, ça va avec le parquet.
Canapé en cuir !
C'est pas moi qui ai choisi ce canapé, j'ai aucune idée de la matière et de tout, mais...
On est vraiment pas mal.
Je suis atteint de la lampe connectable.
C'est-à-dire, c'est une maladie très grave,
tu découvres les lampes connectées
et t'en achètes beaucoup trop.
Beaucoup trop pour un seul homme,
ça ne sert à rien d'en avoir autant.
J'en ai mis derrière la télé, derrière la figurine,
derrière le button de YouTube,
tout en haut de l'étagère, en bas de l'étagère,
derrière le canapé...
C'est une vraie maladie, vous comprenez ?
Y'a un argument qui fait que j'ai acheté tout ça :
- vous allez rire -
les lumières bougent sur le rythme de votre musique. *pause embarrassante*
Vous allez voir, franchement c'est pas mal.
C'est 80% décevant et 20% pas mal.
On y va, c'est parti, on y va !
*Frenetics - "I Feel a Man" en fond*
Voilà.
Cinq cents balles pour ce moment.
*Rire*
Alors juste, anecdote, j'en profite pour remercier tous ceux qui ont bossé pour l'aménagement du bureau, etc.
si j'avais dû faire ça tout seul, j'aurais mis un an,
et le rendu serait vraiment dégueulasse par rapport à là.
Pour vous prouver ça, je vais vous montrer le seul truc que j'ai fait :
c'est coller le bouton qui contrôle toutes les lampes...
... il n'est pas droit.
Et j'suis très fier.
*Rire*
Pour être sincère avec vous, l'ancien décor,
j'étais trop content quand on venait de le faire,
ça allait parfaitement avec ce que j'avais dans ma tête,
ma façon de voir les choses à l'époque, etc...
Mais sauf que, dernièrement,
juste avant qu'on change, j'étais pas très content.
Quand je venais, j'étais un peu...
J'allais dans une pièce qui ne me convient pas,
et je trouve c'est hyper important de se sentir bien chez soi,
et aussi à l'endroit où tu taffes,
surtout quand ça concerne de la création.
Même si je lis des threads, lol.
C'est cool quand l'endroit où tu taffes te plaît et tu te sens bien,
psychologiquement t'es au top,
et en fait, t'as une créativité qu'est meilleure,
t'as envie de venir... Bon, vous savez sûrement de quoi je parle,
mais c'était vraiment important pour moi de changer,
c'est le moment un peu émotion de la vidéo,
le seul.
C'est mon frère qui a bossé sur le décor,
qui a un peu conçu le truc etc...
Et qui est venu aussi faire certaines choses,
bon vous allez voir tout ça
dans un instant...
Bienvenue dans mon nouveau décor !
Et là vous êtes deg' hein!
C'est ça que vous voulez voir, c'est pas ça hein!
Et ben tu vas attendre
la fin pour le WATCHTIME!
Les amis
*Rire*
C'est pas ce que vous croyez putain laissez-moi.
Y'a eu pas mal de trucs qui ont changé au niveau du bureau
mais y'a aussi pas mal de trucs qui sont
restés et je vais essayer
de vous donner aussi des vrais tips,
conseils par rapport au matériel.
Vous avez pas besoin d'avoir exactement le même
matériel que moi pour faire des vidéos,
pas du tout, y'a des trucs qui coûteront bien moins chers,
et qui vous permettront de faire
un résultat quasiment pareil.
Donc voilà.
Ca je voulais juste préciser ça.
*Musique de promotion* Mais est-ce que je vous ai parlé de ce
magnifique clavier Logitech ?
Avec son doux coussin...
*Reniflement*
Il rendra vos prestations sur les jeux vidéos bien meilleures.
Vous ai-je parlé de la souris
Logitech sans fil ?
Avec un temps de réponse quasi-nul.
Pour les pros,
c'est indiqué sur le dessous.
Et attendez!
*Musique de promotion* C'est chiant une souris sans fil:
la recharger c'est énervant;
Vous-ai je parlé du tapis de souris Logitech?
qui permet à cette dernière
de se recharger toute seule,
en étant simplement posée dessus.
Un bon gamer se doit d'entendre ses ennemis arriver.
Et grâce au casque Logitech pro...
Ah! Il est derrière à droite.
J'ai pas du tout été payé par aucune marque pour cette vidéo-là.
Par contre pour être transparent avec vous
Logitech est un sponsor de la chaîne Youtube,
Et en gros il faut que,
quand j'utilises un casque,
ce soit un Logitech.
Voilà.
Mais en vrai mon avis sur le matos,
même si du coup bah,
vous allez vous dire que c'est pas du tout objectif,
heu c'est très bien.
C'était un avis plutôt court mais efficace. *Rire*
Après je suis pas compliqué,
tant que ça fait de la lumière
et que ça fait ce bruit quand on appuie...
*Bruit de touche de clavier* je suis satisfait.
Pour le micro j'ai acheté un Neumann TLM 103.
Il coûte 1000€,
et je ne comprends toujours pas pourquoi.
*Rire*
En vrai j'ai pris un Neumann parce que
quand on a fait des voix pour les courts-métrages,
en studio,
c'était ce micro-là,
et j'trouvais que nos voix étaient vraiment biens,
sauf qu'en fait c'était pas lié au micro,
c'était juste lié au traitement de la voix qu'il y a eu derrière.
Je suis vraiment con
Ok?
Alors il est quand même un peu mieux que celui que j'avais avant,
qui était un AKG P220,
qui coûte je crois dans les 150€,
comme le Rode NT1 qui lui aussi est un très bon micro,
avec un très bon rapport qualité-prix,
donc je vous conseille plutôt l'un de ces deux là plutôt que celui-ci.
Voilà je vais pas vous faire genre que c'est incroyable prenez ça...
Non.
Clairement pas.
Je vous donne les prix et tout pour être transparent
peut-être et vous donner des conseils, si ça vous plaît pas bah...
Bah c'est trop tard pour moi j'aurais dû le savoir avant de tourner.
Aussi j'ai le pied, le Rode, le fameux...
Comment il s'appelle déjà, PSA 1T ?
C'est un ref' trop bizarre.
C'est celui que tout le monde a,
et c'est le même que j'avais dans la première vidéo setup qu'on a fait y'a 3ans,
et il marche toujours nickel,
donc heu, merci Rode pour cette
qualité quand même!
Au niveau de la caméra,
elle n'est pas là parce que c'est John qui est en train de filmer actuellement avec, dans ses mains,
c'est un Sony A7S II,
avec un objectif, un 16-35 de chez Zeiss,
qui est dessus.
Alors pareil c'est une caméra que beaucoup de gens tournent avec,
je sais que Mcfly & Carlito tournent avec aussi,
Cyprien aussi,
sur Bigorneaux & Coquillages on tourne aussi avec...
C'est vraiment une bonne caméra polyvalente qui est hyper bien,
mais elle est aussi chère,
si vous avez un budg' plus petit il y a le,
j'sais qu'il y a le Sony RX 100,
qui est pas mal, c'est d'ailleurs avec cette caméra actuellement que je filme mes lives.
Ca coûte moins cher que cet appareil-là,
c'est plus petit plus compact pour les vlogs aussi c'est très cool.
C'est un bon appareil que j'aime beaucoup,
et je saurais pas vous conseillez d'autres marques
parce que j'ai toujours eu quasiment que du Sony,
à l'époque j'avais le fameux Canon 600D,
mais je suppose qu'il est complètement démodé ?
Ouais il est un peu dépassé.
Enfin bon après pour vous faire un avis le mieux c'est d'aller sur des forums etc...
selon votre budget y'a vraiment, ça peut,
ça peut tout changer quoi.
Donc moi ma caméra elle est reliée à un retour black magic
que je relie avec un cable HDMI,
et en fait ça permet de faire sauter la limite de temps
que y'a sur ces caméras là, on peut faire que des rushs de 25 minutes
sauf que quand t'as la tête dans un casque VR, bah tu vois pas que ça a coupé au bout de 25 minutes
et tu vois pas le temps passer donc t'es double-baisé
alors, au niveau du bureau, c'est le premier vrai bureau trop stylé que j'ai
vraiment de toute ma vie
donc j'suis hyper content, pourquoi ?
pour une chose extrêmement simple,
c'est que ici on a des boutons
et en fait on peut pré-régler une position du bureau
qui permet tout simplement heu.. de changer sa hauteur
Agréable.
alors ça peut vous paraître tout con et anodin,
mais pour certaines vidéos notamment celles où on est plusieurs, on peut beaucoup plus bouger dans l'espace
et être tous dans le cadre
que quand on est assis.
Vous l'avez vu dans les vidéos avec Big Flo et Oli ou même Mcfly et Carlito
quand ils passaient sur ma chaîne
c'était toujours un peu galère y'a toujours un mec qu'est quasiment hors-champ machin
c'était vraiment une tannée.
Etre debout comme on fait sur Bigorneaux et Coquillages
c'est la liberté quoi, à plusieurs c'est vraiment bien.
Et même seul j'trouve y'a un autre mood sur le tournage
et c'est chouette.
Ca peut vous paraître vraiment con, mais ces genres de petites nouveautés
qui donnent l'impression que on reprend un peu à zéro les vidéos,
que on met un pas dans l'inconnu, dans un nouveau truc
alors que c'est tout con quoi c'est juste passer de assis à debout.
Voilà pour le bureau qui est LA grosse nouveauté!
Moi perso c'est LE truc qui me fait kiffer
pour tourner maintenant c'est tourner debout quoi.
*Musique en fond* vous ai-je parlé de l'écran Aorus, 27" 144 Hz
une résolution de 2k avec une dalle IPS ? Je crois pas.
Aorus sponsorise ma chaîne Twitch, cette année
et du coup ils m'ont envoyé un peu de stuff
pour être franc avec vous, je viens de le recevoir aujourd'hui
donc je peux pas vous dire il est bien, il est pas bien
j'en sais putain de rien.
Et mon deuxième écran, en fait je devais recevoir deux Aorus et j'en ai reçu qu'un sur les deux pour le moment
et donc mon deuxième c'est mon ancien écran que je vais changer,
c'est un 24.5" je crois
de la marque...
..."24 pouces et demi"...
C'est un Benq voilà c'est ça j'avais oublié.
Je sais plus la référence mais pour les références exactes elles seront en description,
et c'est un 240 Hz, parce que en fait je pensais qu'en  ayant plus d'image par secondes
je serais meilleur aux jeux
ça ne m'a pas du tout rendu meilleur.
Et la deuxième chose dont je suis très content et qui est aussi une grosse nouveauté pour moi
et ça ça se verra dans toutes les vidéos,
c'est les lumières du studio.
Avant j'avais 2 spots qui étaient sur pieds, et qui étaient un peu approximatifs,
j'en avais rajouté un troisième pour mieux éclairer la porte
fin c'était un peu foireux comme installation
et je dépendais du coup beaucoup de la fenêtre qu'il y a juste là
et je voulais un setup light un peu plus fixe,
parce que mine de rien la lumière c'est hyper important pour avoir une belle image
et moi mon image elle était très hasardeuse:
des fois elle était très jaune des fois très bleue,
Alors Clément il rattrapait ça à l'étalot comme il pouvait
mais c'était
très irrégulier.
Donc on a installé 4 lumières ici:
une qui éclaire le décor,
deux qui éclairent moi et le décor,
et une qui est en contre, qui forme ta silhouette.
En vrai les spots comme ça ça coûte assez cher.
Ce que je vous conseille de prendre c'est,
ce que j'ai pour mon setup live,
c'est juste des petits LED panels, des petits light panels,
y'en a sur Amazon
pour quoi, 50 € ?
Et ça éclaire très bien.
Donc l'avantage de tout ça c'est que c'est relié à l'iPad là
et je peux contrôler toutes les lumières grâce à ça.
Je peux diminuer ou augmenter les lumières,
comme ça.
Ce qui est cool c'est que j'vais pouvoir créer des ambiances en fonction de ce que je tourne.
Là c'est l'ambiance un peu, quand j'tourne un truc quelconque,
et j'ai créé une ambiance pour quand je fais un thread horreur,
hop!
et c'est plus sombre.
Et là la lumière en contre sur moi est rouge aussi.
Mais j'crois que j'ai un problème avec les lampes en général, j'ai un problème.
J'adore la lumière, j'suis un gros kéké mec sur les lumières.
En tout cas maintenant je peux tout contrôler grâce à l'iPad
alors qu'avant je devais me baisser,
et appuyer sur deux boutons,
et franchement heu...
*Rire*
c'est scandaleux quoi !
Au niveau du setup audio je vous ai parlé du micro,
c'est un micro XLR donc il faut une carte son,
pour le relier à son PC.
J'ai rien changé sur ça mais bon je le redis au cas où,
j'ai la Focusrite 2i2,
voilà que tout le monde a et qui fait très bien le taff.
Et j'ai aussi ici un ampli que j'ai pas changé non plus.
Et ce truc là il sert à quoi, il sert à compresser ma voix,
c'est-à-dire que quand je cris,
ça ne sature pas et ça vous détruit pas les oreilles.
"c'est le sang qui est super acide le sang de
OHHH" *Cri saturé*
"... on va mourir AHHHH" *cri non saturé*
Il sert juste à ça, mais dans mon cas,
c'est très vital!
*Rire*
Qu'est ce qu'il va manquer...
Ah la chaise peut-être importante, j'ai pas du tout une chaise de gamer parce que,
j'trouve qu'en vidéo c'est un peu trop imposant.
J'en ai une pour mon setup live,
ah oui peut être je précise,
en fait je dis setup live parce que c'est pas ici du tout que je fais mes lives,
c'est vraiment chez moi.
Ca c'est une chaise qui était vendue par Jarvis,
ceux qui font le bureau.
Je n'ai aucune idée de la référence,
mais c'est une bonne chaise.
...
*Rire*
Ecoute, je l'ai même pas utilisée encore.
C'est horrible, comme l'écran je peux pas vous dire,
mais je suppose qu'elle est bien.
Elle est confortable.
Je crois que j'ai tout dis ...
Oh, le PC ! J'ai pas parlé du PC ...
Oh, incroyable...
Bah écoutez, grosse nouveauté, c'est le même qu'il y a 3 ans.
*Rire*
Rien n'a changé !
Je crois que c'est une GTX NVIDIA 1080,
le processeur...
Je mettrai tout ces détails là en description.
Mais voilà, le PC n'a pas bougé pour la simple et bonne raison que
je fais de moins en moins de gaming et que pour lire des threads et regarder
des vidéos en se filmant sois-même, il n'y a pas besoin d'une machine de guerre.
Ça a des avantages, hein, d'être un escroc.
Bon, cette fois, je crois qu'on est bon !
Est-ce qu'on passe à ...
*Mouvement de caméra approuvant*
Oui, oui !
Les amis, je suis un peu ému, j'espère que ça va vous plaire.
En tout cas, moi ça me plaît. Et, c'est le plus important,
comme je vous l'ai expliqué, se sentir bien dans l’endroit où on tourne.
Le voici...
*Musique*
Comme vous pouvez le constater, deux très grands artistes sont venu dessiner sur le mur.
L'un des deux est d'ailleurs le meilleur illustrateur de Paris.
Est-ce que je dis ça parce qu'il s'agit de mon frère ?
Oui.
Et le second est l'un des meilleurs tatoueurs de Paris aussi, il s'appelle : "Lamine".
Est-ce que je dis ça parce que c'est le meilleur ami de mon frère ?
Oui.
*Rire*
L'idée, c'était de mettre des objets et de dessiner des trucs en rapport avec l'objet autour, sur le mur, à même le mur.
Vous verrez dans les vidéos, ça épouse vraiment la forme de chaque objet.
Là au moins ça change un peu, ça met dans une vraie ambiance un peu adulte et tout,
je trouve ça vraiment cool.
En vrai, c'est super stylé ce qu'ils ont fait, je trouve ça trop cool d'avoir, ces petites touches artistiques
que je ne saurai pas du tout faire moi-même.
Alors, voilà...
Bravo à eux, bravo à tous ceux qui arrivent à faire ça, c'est vraiment fou.
La petite plante, la petite figurine "Terra Formars"...
Vous ai-je parlé de "Tsume Art"?
*Musique* "Tsume Art", figurine qui existe en seulement 600 exemplaires
Ils font les plus belles figurines possibles sur tous les animés japonais inimaginables.
Je viens de bouger la figurine et le fond ne colle plus du tout avec cette dernière.
Je vais devoir retrouver la position dans laquelle elle était.
Est-ce que je rate complètement ma journée ?
*Mouvement de caméra approuvant*
Oui ! *Rire*
Ici, on a une petite mappemonde, je trouve ça cool.
J'adore voyager, j'adore découvrir des cultures, j'adore la diversité.
Donc euh...
*Musique*
Et ici, c'est un masque japonais que j'ai acheté à Asakusa, au Japon.
Ceux qui connaissent, c'est le quartier traditionnel de Tokyo.
Il y a le gros temple.
Voilà, on l'a mis sous cloche pour une raison inconnue. On trouvais ça cool.
*Rire*
Tout n'a pas une explication, je suis désolé
Et surtout, j'ai remis le fameux Dwayne Johnson et le fameur Jackie Chan.
Ils sont posés sur l'étagère.
D'ailleurs je ne les ai même pas nettoyés
on peut voir qu'ils sont absolument dégueulasses !
Et un petit instrument de musique.
J'essaye de me mettre un peu à la musique peu à peu c'est une petite passion que j'ai en scred.
*Bruit d'instrument incoordonné*
*en chantant* J'ai menti !
Et là en fait le tableau le seul truc qui va bouger c'est ça.
En fait ce sera un tableau un tout petit peu plus grand,
de l'illustration que mon frère a fait pour ma chaîne, la bannière,
de ma chaîne Youtube qui ressemble à ça.
Et en gros y'aura un tableau de 50cm sur 50 qui sera ici.
Mais en attendant j'ai mis celui-là parce que j'le trouve vraiment cool,
j'l'avais acheté à Venise et je trouve qu'il est très sympa.
(JOHN) Je pense qu'il y'a un truc derrière.
(SQUEEZIE) Derrière le tableau?
(JOHN) Ouais.
(SQUEEZIE) Tu dis aux gens qu'il y'a un truc parce que j't'ai montré ce qu'il y avait derrière?
(JOHN) Ouais je pense ouais.
(SQUEEZIE) Ok, et ben vous savez quoi ?
Devinez ce qu'il y a derrière le tableau.
Allez-y.
C'est un dessin sur un mur,
ce sera le secret de mon décor.
On crée un mythe.
Je le révélerais un jour: dans 1 mois, 1 an, 2 ans...
On sait pas.
Essayez de deviner ce que c'est *rire*
Vous prenez pas trop la tête c'est un truc tout con.
Et là pareil la petit illu' sur la porte, on savait pas quoi marquer...
"Pourquoi on marquerait pas porte sur la porte?"
Et la petite touch',
Y'a quand même un truc que moi j'ai imaginé dans ce décor,
c'est quoi ?
Devinez.
*Musique de jeu télévisé*
Mais oui la réponse B !
La LED !
Ca c'est la touch' de Lucas hein !
Ah dès qu'il y'a de la lumière, Lucas le kikoo est passé par là hein !
*Musique nostalgique* Voilà. J'espère vraiment que ça va vous plaire.
Je sais que ça va vous brusquer,
moi aussi ça m'a brusqué au début, j'étais en mode:
AHH !
C'est tellement un changement radical que,
c'est une nouveauté qui fait un peu peur,
et surtout j'suis très nostalgique quoi:
j'ai vécu tellement de moments dans l'ancien décor, tellement de trucs incroyables,
et puis c'était surtout la première fois,
dans l'ancien décor,
que je tournais ailleurs que chez moi mes vidéos,
donc j'avais un affec' particulier.
Mais là c'est vraiment une page qui se tourne,
je suis un peu ému mais je suis aussi très malade,
du coup peut-être qu'il faut terminer cette vidéo.
*Rire*
Je vous remercie
pour toutes ces années et j'espère que cette année on va faire de trop bonnes vidéos ensemble.
Le mot d'ordre cette année c'est:
"J'me fait kiffer"
sur YouTube j'fais ce que j'ai envie de faire.
Voilà, c'est avec une petite émotion,
que nous arrivons à la fin de cette vidéo.
Et puis on se retrouve très vite dans une prochaine,
à cet endroit du coup.
A bientôt !!
Et merci c'est grâce à vous que j'ai pu faire le décor un peu, de mes rêves !
Parce que mine de rien ça coûtait
de l'argent d'acheter ce truc,
de peindre, de mettre du parquet, d'acheter les trucs, de faire venir les gens pour graffer...
Et j'ai pu le faire,
donc merci à vous, une fois de plus parce que,
sans vous j'aurais jamais pu le faire.
Allez à bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo,
Tchao les gens gros bisouuus !
J'ai dit gros bisous on en est là.
*Musique d'outro*